[音楽]
それじゃあ肇社長です皆さん富士急ハイランドにある戦慄迷宮ご存知でしょうか
結構有名だと思うんですけど俗にお化け屋敷ですねめちゃくちゃ強いと言われているお
化け屋敷なんですけど僕も結構掛けてかそういうお化け屋敷苦手なんですけどもしこの
めっちゃくちゃ子はいー戦慄迷宮というお化け屋敷に史上最強
2 bd の男を入れたらどうなるのかやってみたいと思いますで何か今性について今
聞いたんですけど7月にリニューアルされてるらしくて
なっちゃくパックキャッチてるらしい俺の知る高でのもっとボビーリーの音を持って
いきましょう
矢田違うデザインボランティアや違う違うからであるんだけど
ええけんすけでたればホラー映画見てても一人だけ
映画墨出器かけないくらいめっちゃ怖いものが嫌いで全図
ありました戦慄迷宮入りなきゃダメ持っている方だと思うんですよ嫌ですか
いや前回行ったんですって言ったら本当にも常にいやーそれがれて入ったんですよ1個
目間にコメント頃でも僕が出来ました僕前からそこに対していく1月にリニューアルし
てもっと多くなってんだって
でかつて帰りたいしてるとこがいいですよ改修後せんだよねこの男
ビビってるのわかってるし嫌がってるのわかってるけどなんとかして俺がな
このけど俺がこの日ビルの彼を何とかしてなんとか気合いでボールまくって導くんで彼
の精神状態を見てみました
やだぞ剣で早速この男と戦慄迷宮最後まで何と思いますひざん
忘れてるじゃあ行ってきまーす
ではいってきます
自己これすごいん
dee
ああああああああ
ああああああ
ame
me
uh
はいというわけでもうすぐ数えますどうですか
を終わりました終わりました今
オープニングを見終わってこっから中で増えている
戦慄迷宮でさせるってすごいことだね撮影金賞とってもやるきゃねー
お悩みです
j a ジャズマン20
ああああああ
やばいやばいやばいぜってほっからくるじゃん流行や
時もこれ
ブーバーし
しちゃうっていうとイケると思っています
nara ちょっと寄って始まった
続いてぼっち系ボスって6年前としてフォロワー
ああああああ
[音楽]
ところじゃないところではだよもう
もっとな上リーダーやああ
[音楽]
ブーブー sa ああああ
はこの医者は上鴻山旅ロガーニャー
ブーバしてくるかあぁぬーっ
すっごいたのかいたところどちらで岩場であったらと危ないから w 大丈夫だと思う
が終わってくれるすっごいっ
入るとみたいなすいませんでした米したいいたしましたありがとうございました
ああああああ
rar
andare わー
汗見てむー
1本当にあの世こっから先がないとますです
これいかなくても思うじゃないですか
戦いですここでリタイアしたら
単純にたたかれるぞ
では
[音楽]
ブーバーだよねー
ここ休めるよ
me
ルカー滝は祭ダメゼッタイ置くやつ
image はっはっは
4日3号ああ
re スキル e 02 f
大丈夫2倍払ういやマジで大丈夫だけってまーす ride a 大丈夫マンス者上で
大丈夫
会場で大丈夫持ってきてないですね入ってなくてこの教材で濃淡にもれた女郎と言える
ああああああ
なんて目つぶりたいよねまでこのほとんどたーーー
どんだけを愛しいよおねしょを知らせんじゃない
er わー
あああああ
2わー
ran うわぁ
ana
ああああああああ
ふぅ
ウェアー4わーわー
ええええええ
tan
まず un 退け6読響キャリ持つ
わー
goo
yeah
ああああああ
ani
can you do が一番 see
貼って自分の街が楽しいスポーツ
メジャー2
al
[拍手]
何を
rar
彼は私までドングル
ああああああ俺どんなきゃいけないのよねー
yeah
me
あのううぅうぅううう
ファイター朝青縫う時も千代パンヌード
rar
ザッハー
uh
male
[拍手]
car
[音楽]
toranoana
うーんまぢでコア見て俺らせ
混ぜれ号行っ東
4つ良かったッ
どうやって決めてる風変わった